Speaker 1: Let's talk a little bit about
conspiracy theories and fear mongering and
using fear as a tool to influence. We're going to
look at one of the usual suspects, Tulsi Gabbard.
But we're also going to look at a guy named I
this I hesitate, Dr. John Campbell, not a medical
doctor and relevantly not a medical doctor. In
a second segment, this may surprise some of you,
but we will get to that. Let's start with and
the theme here is using fear and, you know,
irritating and scaring people. Agitating and
scaring people. Tulsi Gabbard was on Fox News's
The Five yesterday. And Tulsi, I know that the
word is now in the in the lexicon sanctimoniously
bemoaned the use of fear to manipulate people. And
of course, Tulsi herself is one of the people who
has used fear to manipulate people, particularly
since coming out against the Democratic Party and
becoming an anti-vaccine, anti-trans spokesperson
of sorts. So let's start as it makes sense to do,
listening to what Gabbard herself said,
and then we'll talk about why it's
particularly rich that she make this claim.
Speaker 3: Does anybody ever get held for any
wrongdoing? It's it's frightening that the
answer to that is probably no at this point.
They can continue to lie. One of the things
that I took away from the statement that the
Gore should wrote was.
Speaker 1: Gosh, it's.
Speaker 3: Here that he used COVID as the example.
But really what we know throughout history,
going back to the Cold War and the post-9-11
now, this new Cold War is that when we have
people in positions of power fomenting fear,
it makes it easier for them to take away our
freedoms. And so the big warning signal, kind
of the right alert for everyone, is as soon
as you start to see people in power overhyping a
situation or a threat, fomenting fear, we have to
go back and remember Benjamin Franklin's famous
quote, that those who would give up essential
liberty to purchase a little temporary safety and
security deserve neither security nor liberty.
Speaker 2: Well said.
Speaker 1: Poignant words from
Tulsi Gabbard. Now, of course, Tulsi has done a
campaign for a while now portraying herself as
the victim of the fear mongering by the Democratic
establishment, where people said, Oh, you'll see
the wolf in sheep's clothing or below. Tulsi is
one of the great practitioners of fear mongering
to influence and manipulate herself, and she
uses the fear mongering as a tool to advance her
interests and her ambitions. She wants to be seen
and unfortunately some fell for it and saw her as
this principled anti-war activist who will always
expose the lies of the fear mongers and the war
mongers. But in reality, she has turned out to be,
and I want to be accurate, a pro authoritarian,
conspiratorial fearmonger who actually has
fomented the very fear and division among
Americans that she pretends to go after when
she has called Democratic leaders, warmongers
who will get us into, whether it's World War
Four or five or a nuclear armed Armageddon,
that was fear mongering, that made no sense and
was not factually based in any way. Check out
her appearance on the Joe Rogan program. Rather
than ever addressing the substantive criticisms
of her foreign policy views or explain why did you
meet with Syrian dictator Bashar al Assad in 2017.
She simply uses fear to portray herself as this
persecuted, almost whistleblower who was exposing
the corruption of the establishment. And if people
ask too many questions about why she met with that
dictator, then next thing you know, it'll be 1984.
She has said that whistleblowers and dissenters
were being silenced by the government and that
therefore we all need to worry about eroding
democracy and freedom with no real substantive
criticism of the way that the Trump administration
singlehandedly made a free press the enemy
of the people, which actually is something
that we should be afraid of. And of course, it's
always without specifics about who is it exactly
that's doing any of this stuff. And there's so
many examples. In October of 2022, she posted
a video on Instagram which accused the Democratic
Party of stoking anti-white racism and undermining
law enforcement when the reality is that police
have not been defunded and that the so-called
divisive agenda of Democrats on race, it's mostly
a reaction to the outrageous anti-woke stuff from
the right. But that's not what she tells you.
She just makes you afraid of the Democrats and
the things that they're going to do. And we
could go on. You know, when she spoke at CPAC,
she fearmongering about how the. Biden vaccine
mandates and so-called lockdowns were attacks
on civil liberties and personal freedoms, the
likes of which we will never recover from. And
it will be a slippery slope into wokeness stand
or whatever. Ignoring the public health benefits,
ignoring scientific evidence and all these things.
She wants to sanctimoniously go after those who
use fear when it's hard to imagine someone
who has used fear more than Tulsi herself.
So there's that. Let's now go to another
sort of example of this, Dr. John Campbell.